well you and justin looking great i just
heard him joke to the photographers
you're asking for a single but i'm gonna
have a double when this is all over um
is this date night for mom and dad you
get to have a little fun tonight yeah i
mean anytime we're leaving our house is
like a date night i think these days
it's always fun to celebrate um you know
something that you're proud of
and to do it with him and have a glass
of wine like it it feels special it does
well i mean i have to give you a belated
happy mother's day as well are you a mom
too i'm a stepmom so happy mother's day
thank you how are you celebrated what'd
you guys do
my kids um
made me the cutest t-shirt that said
best mom in life
which means you know they wrote it you
know i'm like love it
and then a canvas bag with hand prints
and footprints and it was so cute and
then i left and and did my own thing for
a few hours which was the best thing
that's what you deserve right
you know what you just need a little bit
of a break because when you come back
you're better for everybody you know
yeah that little me time means a lot
yeah it does
well we're here at the fyc event i mean
the show and your performance getting
beyond rave reviews
how does that feel and how would it feel
for the show to be nominated
oh my god it would um
i mean any kind of nomination just feels
like
unbelievable because
when you're when you're working on a
show
you just want to tell the story and
you really cannot think about it
in terms of
expectations of of who will see it and
who will like it and what will happen to
it you just can't think about it in
those terms at all
so you're kind of working in a vacuum
and when people actually like it
it's just startling and you're like oh
my god really me too i like it too you
know you i'm a big fan
of the show i think it i think all of
our directors and our
amazing show runner robin and nick our
co our co-creator
i mean i'm just
i'm just in awe of these guys you know i
just love working with these people so
i'm really proud of it and it'd be
amazing but also it would be amazing no
matter what the experience was amazing
so they're all in awe of you every
single person is like jessica in this
show um so it's just incredible to see
i have to ask you know the show we
talked a little bit about this at the
junket the show is this story of women
who you know of course there's a dark
side but it's also about the stresses of
parenting and of marriage and of of love
and all that um and you know you guys
just celebrated 10 years i think are
about to right
yeah we are can you give me or in the
audience any insight how do you maintain
that spark and that connection and that
joy that you two have
it's a really good question right um
well i'll have to give justin the credit
in this moment
for this one thing that he always says
to me is we might be married but we have
to keep dating
and it's so true you know
you just have to keep making time for
each other and you have to keep making
each other a priority
and do the things that you love together
um it's not always easy as we all know
but that
those touch point moments i think
kind of
make all the hard times
you know palatable i guess
well you guys seem to have built a house
full of love together i mean you got
your boys and he's here looking very
proud of you tonight thank you